cool guys we'll see you tomorrow
all right jesus
i was um yesterday on day we've gone
through all the hallmark
christmas movies they're so bad newer
ones or older ones both doesn't matter
because you just crank them out walmart
christmas movies and then i was asking
i think they're a money laundering
scheme
process i wonder i was wondering who
makes worse movies lifetime or hallmark
and i think lifetime but made for tv
movies obviously
call mark's better huh i think
hallmark's better
yeah you're big laurie laughs no no
they're both bad they're both
no they're well just her schemes to get
her kids through college
but i went through the list and there i
went through the list of home i didn't
go through all of them i don't do
the list of like the best life to worst
lifetime movies
and just the titles alone are [ __ ]
amazing
and and like and then they just change
the movies they'd be like
hey don't we have that old movie called
a woman struggle and they're like yeah
all right we're gonna change it to a
woman struggle at christmas and we're
just gonna add christmas trees and a
couple of
a couple of wreaths and then they can
double that up be like a woman's new
year struggle
and then they're just like woman
struggle colin new year new me
listen i really uh the focus groups are
uh we're looking at the data here and
these people they don't seem too keen on
uh the mother being
by santa claus can we can we make it one
of the elves i think if it's one of the
elves it's just a problem with seeing
santa claus for people
well santa claus isn't shocked no
because he'd be taking toys from people
no mel gibson plays man
is playing him in that fat man movie
definitely not if santa was just she
would leave little chocolate coins out
for him
he would take little chocolate coins
from you there was a santa claus his
name was the grinch
if santa claus was just he would call
all the kids houses
and drop off toys and then leave a bill
29
interest oh that's [ __ ] up man
plus gas i had to go to the store and
get the toys
it was a very long line
um let me can i can i do the night the
19 most
just the 19 most ridiculous lifetime
movies just the titles i'm going to read
but if you read what they're about
you ready from straight a's to xxx
do okay okay how about this let's do
this do you want to look oh this game's
gonna be fun we have a little fun guys
shut up
do you want to guess okay i'm gonna read
the title but i want to see if you can
guess what the movie's about this will
be fun this will be fun all right
i'll tell you what there's 19 there's 19
movies if you can get 10 i'll give you a
dollar
okay okay ready okay from straight a's
to xxx
obviously young bright aspiring student
uh gets into the seedy world of
pornography
okay so that's what's easy number two
baby for sale
i mean i'm assuming that there is a
an exchange at some point for a baby for
money in this movie
okay so you've gotten two restless
virgins
um a bunch of uh well it's just
basically what a low rent american
pirate buff
and then one of them gets aids okay well
restless virgins
is a sex scandal that shook
massachusetts prep school
milton academy in the 2004 year oh so
like american pie but
for white people instead of a bunch of
jewish teenagers right okay so that's
not a comedy basic so you didn't get
that you got two though it's not bad
uh newlywed and dead um
dude keeps killing his wives um but you
don't find that out till later in the
movie so he marries this woman he gets a
life insurance policy kills her
and then they investigate the guy and
find out that he's killed other wives
before right
a young newlywed begins without her
husband's love when his rival is found
dead
when she starts invading investigating
the death and her next hus
and her my husband's past she becomes
the next target
it's the same movie
this is it's not even don't even be
impressed because it's lifetime
they only remake the same movie
okay fine what about drink slay love
uh drink slay love uh
is about a um up-and-coming restaurateur
who um is murdering his lovers
i know a 16 year old vampire masquerades
as a high school student in order to
recruit unsuspecting victims
okay they're going with the vampires
remember remember that movie came out
when twilight was big
enough the next one i hate these names
i me wed i me
wed um
somebody uh marries a wreath
come on no what i'm being serious
whatever the word
i don't know what the word is now
whatever you're calling those doo doo
doos
somebody married one of those things
i would think right is it like an i am
sam but like
when isabelle darden a successful
attractive 30 year old woman
grows tired of people asking her when
you're gonna get married she decides to
honor the person she loves the most by
marrying herself
that was an easy one man i mean wed you
shouldn't be able to guess that one
uh numbers okay so the next one the
secret of hidden lake
um secret if you see this is a va these
some of these are vague secret of hidden
lake
you could should still probably be able
to get it is about
a small town okay
and so far so good high school soccer
coach is
banging all the students no a woman
returns to her small town to investigate
her father's death
which authorities consider a hunting
attack did he die in the lake
i mean i don't i haven't seen the movie
when i watch it i'll tell you my father
must die
i mean i'm assuming this is a movie
about a
a revenge it's like kill bill but
instead of bill it's her dad
what if it was an autobiography about
george bush jr
abusing an old man she's the hero mike
that's it
no no no no i need to bring this up like
she's the hero of the story
can we make no no no no no no no no
she's a hero she's
she's abusing an elderly stroke victim
how is this woman not the hero
i need to start by saying that clearly
obviously domestic violence is wrong
and nobody should be abusing people in
their homes
right i agree nobody should be hitting
their wives right
but coming back after the dude has had a
stroke
and torturing him and killing him while
he can't while he's incompetent
that's worse right it feels worse it
feels worse right
the next one is grumpy cat's worst
christmas ever
okay this one's easy so this is a
christmas movie
and it's it's like a beethoven but the
cat is like the star of the movie
and there's all kinds of wacky hijinks
one of the parents wants to get rid of
the cat
but then eventually at the end he warms
up to the cat a grumpy cat grumpy cat's
internet meme sensation with over six
million
oh god it's that grumpy cat the guy this
before the cat died
who has graced the cover of new york
magazine is a spokesperson for american
idol blah blah blah blah but that's
pretty much the story it's
you know grumpy cat or whatever uh this
one's good you'll never figure this one
out
deadly daycare yes
deadly daycare just any
daycare that's run by blood
daycare literally any daycare that i see
on the news every year
three month old toddler beaten
after a few years of financial hardship
a young mother rachel
decides to go back to work to help her
ex-husband with mounting bills
with no one to watch their four-year-old
daughter the mother decides to enroll
her in the local daycare center called
little ones owned by seemingly
responsible older woman
after a few weeks mia's owned by owned
by local entrepreneur
efri jepstein so apparently they were
beating the daughter in the school
uh i do but i don't
i'm just reading it how it's about i'm
just i'm just i'm just reading it
i do but i don't so
um a woman has to uh choose between
marrying a guy that she's
she knows is good for her but she's not
in love with them so now she has to
choose between
settling down or living her best life
denise richards plays lauren a divorced
wedding planner who falls for the groom
to be
dean kane oh my god can we see that
can we watch that one can we do that
denise richards and dean cain are you
[ __ ] kidding me
but i are you [ __ ] kidding me we have
to see this movie the
entire movie the entire movie's on
youtube by the way for free
the whole movie it's on youtube if
you're gonna oh my god we have to watch
this
i do but i don't but i don't
and is she all like is she like have her
all like in the in the posters
like her with her wedding planner stuff
and a cake and she's going
what like what am i doing
i do but i don't so i can't okay here
it's a movie it's it's a movie starring
denise richards
uh and the topic of the movie is her uh
is her getting her aids uh test back
by the way yeah that's what it is i do
but i don't is
what charlie sheen said to denise
richards when she said do you have aids
i do what i know and he went look i do
and i don't okay i [ __ ] i cured
myself all right winning
she was like look you're [ __ ] three
months late on alimony like this has to
stop
god scott dean kane looks exactly the
same well this is from 2004.
oh okay i was like so this is younger
game god both their careers have been
[ __ ] that long
denise richards too yeah oh yeah cause
denise richards had a little they gave
her a little run there for a bit
starship troopers yeah but are we gonna
get any
is there any clips where somebody says
anything oh i think somebody just made a
music fan video
first off how does this movie have a fan
video
but secondly here i'll tell you how
royce
oh my god that's the gay guy of course
absolutely gorgeous lauren i
hated it not because she didn't look
beautiful but because it was like the
dress i wore at my wedding
oh the writing's really good the writing
the delivery of the lions i i don't know
if i could make it through this movie
it's only an hour and 27 minutes long we
probably only oh it's gonna be out of
style
well that's short for a feature like
film
it's long for a waterboarding it's you
know what i mean like you're going out
it's only an hour and twenty minutes oh
i get it i'm
only gonna dunk you under the water for
an hour i do what i don't
i do but i don't think there's a church
involved
i'm skipping through it the acting gets
really good
uh oh this is that i'm not look spoiler
alert at the end
dean cain falls in love with her turns
out he's superman
mike [ __ ] dean kane dude oh god the
next title okay
the next title mike is a side order of
life
so that's obviously we got a restaurant
employee or an owner probably a waitress
um who i guess falls in love i don't
know
it's it's everything's the same thing a
photographer reevaluates her life when
her best friend is diagnosed with cancer
so it's a comedy it's hilarious
uh the next one is my little assassin
obviously spy kids rip off right little
kid
it's actually a lot darker than that to
be honest with you my little assassin
marta lorenzo checks into a havana hotel
and in a flashback remembers 22 years
before
at age 19 visiting cuba from new york
she comes she comes to the attention
of fidel castro the country's rebel
president he invites her to be his
secretary
and part and be part of the making of
the new cuba she accepts but soon learns
he already has a capable secretary
martha's duties lie somewhere else she
becomes pregnant
she also comes to the attention of the
fbi and cia so when she wakes up in a
u.s hospital after what may have been a
botched abortion against her will in
cuba
her government presses her into service
and it was set into
as an assassin her job is to go back to
cuba and
kill her former lover wow and then the
baby
turns out they didn't abort it it's
still alive
justin trudeau that's true but just
really abortion
uh we're almost done here baby monitor
colon sound of fear
um the baby monitors are picking up
other sounds of
other crimes 1998 if that helps
a neglectful mother overhears her
husband on the telephone at their
workplace
talking with their babysitter she
discovers they are having an affair
and going to have a baby
that sucks because then you're just
creating a whole a perpetual loop of
having to hire babysitters
and you're gonna knock that one up and
then you have to hire another one
got another one for you will you marry
me m-e-r-r-y will you marry
me um
so joseph and mary after not getting a
room at the end
undergo a a series of misadventures and
wacky comedic
side quests uh spoiler alert turns out
to judith
yeah and then um mary virgin mary is
played by
denise richards it's actually when
wendy malik and joseph's played by dean
gaines
you might be right i rebecca
from an upperclass los angeles family
and henry from acquire singing
tradition-bound midwestern roots
are in love henry pops a question just
before christmas
wow sounds like a whole movie stalked by
a doctor
i mean this person is stalked by their
doctor
that's pretty much it yeah i mean that's
come on wait till helen comes
so this guy he's got uh premature
ejaculation issues
and they're like come on dude at least
wait till she gets off
when a reconstructed family moves to a
converted church in a county
molly must save her new troubled
stepsister from a dangerous relationship
with a desperate
ghost of a young girl yeah i hate when
the ghosts
do that we have two more the last
prostitute
the last prostitute is the name of the
uh of the film
the last prostitute what do you think um
it's about the it's about the uh
the life and times of lauren southern
okay close here's the trailer
what began as an innocent adventure now
you'll be careful in those canoes
became the summer that changed their
lives
uncle charlie just said she's gorgeous
how gorgeous like marilyn monroe or
gorgeous like jane russell
bert she's the best in the world we know
that you probably charged a lot
but maybe you could just figure it by
the minute i don't eat
anymore what do you mean you're like
retired most peculiar damn woman i ever
saw
if you want to work for me work work
trying to run a horse farm
but she sees all the work we're going to
do for her she'll
definitely [ __ ] us
name your price but here's what i don't
get right like
you you went on this trip to have sex
with a hooker yes you brought money for
a hooker
yes so wouldn't you just go oh oh can
you do you have any referrals can you
send us to it
can i get another hooker yeah i'm not
gonna sit here and paint your [ __ ]
barn all summer like i'm just
can you find a hooker that has a
comparable price
i'm gonna let you do it it is what we
can keep that in mind
and i love how every throwback movie
people try to make to try to make it
seem authentic they're like
whoa is she pretty like marilyn monroe
or is she pretty like a for gardner like
it's always like these
gee willy yeah let's go out and play
stick balls and we'll talk about marilyn
monroe
they always try to add these name drop
these old [ __ ] celebs it's so cheesy
i for one think this is the most
underrated star trek movie
this is not a star trek movie uh why is
wesley in it
oh my god is that really why is wesley
in it is that really yeah that's what
wheaton
quill queen that's what waiting oh my
gosh why is the end of it's not a star
trek movie because his career is
terrible
oh yeah that's right all right and then
there was one more mother mate
uh wait wait no uh is a mother man sleep
with danger
mother may i sleep with danger uh
starring denise richards it's an account
word for word of her relationship with
charlie sheen look that's not true but
i'm gonna give it to you
his name was carlos danger you did you
did pretty good you did pretty good i'm
not gonna lie
it's the anthony weiner story the
scarlet
oh [ __ ] uh all right look uh winning
remember that remember tiger blood dude
it got played out but let's be fair
if people had to run that into the
ground that was one of the greatest
meltdowns in the history of america
charlie sheen's meltdown was so much fun
until
everybody had the ah tiger blonde
winning it was like everyone killed but
when charlie did it it was [ __ ]
amazing it was the greatest thing ever